you are so not gonna believe this
our very first external matter human
cyclist could change my whole life we're
gonna check this out right not alone
mari mccabe she moves fast compared to
who
hey youtubers it's Charlie so big news
the flash season 2 has cast the voice of
zoom it's gonna be Tony Todd you may
know him from the Candyman films he's
got a ton of star trek the producers
have already said a little bit about
what's going on with the character so
I'm gonna do a breakdown of that and
explain what it means in this promo with
Barry Allen in the blue lightning what
it looks like is going on here is that
he is just getting faster and the Blue
Lightning is a result of that it's just
an expression of him getting faster
there were a lot of theories in that
first promo they teased at Comic Con
it's like is this gonna be the zoom
character what's going on why is there
blue lightning I think it's just a way
to differentiate that Barry Allen is
getting faster and faster just look at
how fast he zooming all over the world
right now so they said in season 2 they
wanted to do to do something a little
bit different with their big villain
character they wanted to go with another
speedster another evil speedster and
zoom is the Geoff Johns reverse-flash
now in the Silver Age comics Barry Allen
was the main flash his Big Bad was
Professor zoom a Oh Bart Thawne now they
used him as the season 1 big bad and
what happened in the comics is is after
crisis on Infinite Earths back during
the 1980s Wally West took the mantle of
the flash and then mutt you know much
much later many years after that Geoff
Johns took over the flash title and
brought back Barry Allen and flash
rebirth but as part of that he also
transitioned to new versions of old
characters so he brought back and
updated a lot of the classic Rogues he
updated Barry Allen himself but when he
transitioned to the new version of the
reverse flash he made it a whole
different character and he made the
story much more personal so AO bar
thawne's reverse-flash existed at the
same time that this new reverse flash
existed now the numerous flash was
hunter zolomon
he called himself zoom juice he dropped
the professor title on top of that to
make him more threatening Geoff Johns
changed the way that his speed worked so
that he could be faster than Wally West
now if all the Flash's powers are based
on the Speed Force then they all should
have similar abilities so the way around
that is is that Geoff Johns said that
hunter Zola Mont existed out of time
after an accident he got in an accident
with the cosmic treadmill and and as a
result of that it faced his body out of
sync with the normal flow of time so
zoom from the comics moves in between
the spaces in time he's not moving
through space like every
else like when you walk down the street
also as a side effect of that it made
his voice sound really weird like he
would slur his speech because it was
stretched out through time so what the
producer said is is on the TV show what
they're gonna do is they cast someone to
do the voice to do like the big Darth
Vader booming crazy voice and a
different actor is gonna be inside the
actual suit but if you remember AO Bart
on suit in season one he had like a
yellow version of Barry Allen's suit
that's straight out of the comics in
season two they said that they wanted to
make it completely CG they wanted it to
seem more like he wasn't wearing a suit
they wanted there to be more confusion
about where his body ended and where the
suit began so what they're gonna do is
they're gonna use the same effects that
they used to create Gorilla Grodd to
create the reverse-flash suit of season
2 now here's the twist though zoom on
the TV show is not going to be hunter
zolomon is not going to be just like the
comics the TV show and season 1 blended
a lot of Barry Allen things with Wally
West things from the comics so they're
gonna do the exact same thing as season
2 whenever they were explaining like how
it was gonna work with the different
voice in the in the different physical
actor they were talking about Star Wars
they were like we wanted to do the Darth
Vader thing where there was still a
mystery about who was inside the suit
even though you were hearing the voice
before they announced that Tony Todd was
only doing the voice of zoom there were
a lot of theories that because he's an
african-american and the Wally West
they're bringing young the show is also
a black actor zoom might be an evil
future version of Wally West because in
the new 52 part of the Wally West's
origin story the african-american Wally
West is that an evil blue costume
wearing version of Barry Allen comes
back in time to try and change the past
but in order to do so he has to kill
himself so it's like an evil version of
a main character from the future coming
back in time to try and change the past
so what I think they might be doing on a
TV show is taking a lot of pieces from
the Jeff Jones era comics like the
hunter zolomon zoom and combining it
with some of the new 52 things about
Wally West just mixing and matching a
lot of story elements now it's not gonna
be right out of the comics they're not
doing an exact storyline but it will
flow a lot from flash rebirth just
because that dealt with two versions of
the perverse flash but the first time
that we will actually hear him speak on
screen the first time we'll hear that
Tony Todd zoom voice is in an episode
called the flash of two worlds which I
know everybody recognized
is the first issue in the comics when
Barry Allen met Jay Garrick now this is
actually a little confusing because
Grant Gustin actually said in an
interview that we would learn who the
Big Bad was in the first episode of the
season in the title of the first episode
is the man who saved central city so
it's probably gonna happen is is we'll
just see a CG version of zoom on screen
and he'll like he'll run off and we
won't see him again to the flash of two
worlds
we'll have to see episode by episode
some of the things that they changed in
the comics but just expect like a few
minor changes but thematically a lot of
the energy will flow from like the first
time Barry Allen meet Jay Garrick the
reason that zoom becomes a villain so
when you're thinking about zoom theories
just think about an evil version of a
character that we already know but
remember his voice will sound completely
different it's not going to be the
modulated thing that they did with the
first flash in Barry Allen and season
one it's gonna sound like booming scary
Candyman voice and because the episode
that we first hear him speak is called
the flash of two worlds I think he's
definitely going to be from earth 2
he'll be an earth 2 version of a
character that we probably already met
or a character that we meet in the first
episode typically what happens with TV
shows is is that all the pieces of the
fanatic like all the clues is so like
what's going on in the finale are teased
in the first episode so once we get that
first episode we'll have most of the
clues that we need I know everybody's
wondering about when the trailer is
gonna drop just because the first
episode is coming like the sixth and the
seventh like the flash and arrow and
next week it's a little out of sync
that's what I'm thinking that's gonna
happen they're gonna air it next Tuesday
but there's there's no confirmation on
that that's just a theory typically what
you see is like first big promos for TV
shows debut about four weeks before the
actual premiere but because that falls
on a weekend because it's like a little
out of sync I think it'll probably next
Tuesday like it'll air on the same day
that the TV shows air on so I don't
think that we're gonna see like the new
flash trailer on the exact same day that
we see the arrow trailer like they'll
probably the flash trailer first and the
next day they'll do the arrow trailer
I've already done a couple videos about
some of the new speedsters that they're
bringing on they're bringing on a lot of
speedsters but they might not all become
speedsters right away so Wally West for
instance you know might not be a
speedster right away the first time we
meet him he might become a speedster
through the course of the season and the
same thing with Jesse quick I just saw
some of you guys commenting that they're
like oh wow it seems like
bringing on too many speedsters I mean
they're just bringing the characters on
they're not all gonna be flashes all at
the same time probably maybe by the
finale but that's like a whole season of
TV away and if you guys weren't sure all
the big bads from arrow in the flash
will go to legends of tomorrow so the
zoom character and damian darhk-- from
arrow they'll both be part of legends of
tomorrow but the big bad for that show
is Vandal Savage we don't know if
they're all going to be working together
if they're gonna be doing like a version
of in Justice Society or something like
that
zoom though you guys can let me know do
you think that he's going to be in earth
to evil version of a good character that
we know right now really quick heads up
to what's gonna happen is is once we do
get that flash trailer is I'm gonna do
arrow and flash giveaways what I'm gonna
try to do I mean I would love to give
away Jay Garrick hats but I don't think
the DC Direct is gonna be making those
till next year is they do make reverse
flash rings now so I'm gonna try and
give away gift certificates for reverse
flash ring so you guys could just have
them shipped to you wherever you live so
I'm gonna try and figure that out the
next week or so because I think this
year for like flash and arrow Legends
tomorrow those kind of giveaways I'll
give away reverse flash rings and if we
do see Green Lantern stuff on arrow I'll
totally look into giving away power
rings too I think it's more likely that
Carol Ferris is gonna be a part of the
arrows storyline but I'll talk about
that in my green Lancer and green arrow
video that I'll be posting soon be sure
to subscribe to get all that stuff if
there's any specific flash or arrow
videos that you guys want or characters
the allow me to explain just let me know
in the comments and if you didn't see
they just confirmed that you're on
Greyjoy is gonna be a part of Game of
Thrones season 6 I've already done a ton
of videos about him so I'll put some
links in the description if you want to
learn more about your on Greyjoy so much
huge stuff happening this week also you
know force Friday if you don't know what
that is
Star Wars is doing like a mega unboxing
event so I'm gonna do a force Friday
video it's like the ultimate shut up and
take my money so wait you guys wait for
more flash and arrow stuff you can click
here for the lash flash promo that aired
and you can click here to learn all
about Jesse quick also I included some
Game of Thrones links in the description
just because they had some casting stuff
today so thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight